is the most senior hamas figure to have
been killed by the israelis since 2014
so a significant strike
by israel and one that we might see
retaliation from
from hamas hamas have certainly not let
up in their attempts to
bombard parts of israel again the towns
of
ashkelon and ashdod have been targeted
today
and i was in a briefing with an itf and
israeli defence force commander
earlier this morning and they estimate
that the hamas stockpiles of rockets is
anywhere between 20 and 30
000. so uh it is their analysis their
assessment that if hamas
wants to uh continue this fight it could
do so
uh for some time although they wouldn't
put any specific time
frame on that however
it is their belief the israeli's belief
that um if it comes to it
they have the greater firepower and and
frankly they do
and if they need to send in ground
troops then they are at least
maneuvering them
into a position where that that will be
possible if necessary i think that will
be
yet another game changer in this um
escalating violence if it does come to
that
in the meantime the hope is that by
pulling strings behind the scenes by
appealing to
the leaders of various different
factions to calm
their own populations and with world
leaders uh trying to press upon the
leaders of
israel and palestine there will be some
sort of diplomatic resolution to this
before long